massen infektionen corona massen
infektion in unserem großen fleisch
betrieben fleischfabriken kann man sagen
davon haben wir in den vergangenen tagen
und wochen gehört und das hat dazu
beigetragen dass wir und die politik die
regierung da man ein bisschen genauer
hingeschaut hat endlich und heute auch
gehandelt wäre er hat im bundeskabinett
harte maßnahmen beschlossen hat gegen
diese zustände in den unterkünften vor
allen dingen der arbeitnehmer in diesen
fleischfabriken nämlich höhere bußgelder
beschlossen hat und ein komplettverbot
der werksverträge und unter anderem
darüber wollen wir jetzt sprechen mit
der bundeslandwirtschaftsministerin
julia klöckner die direkt aus dem
kabinett quasi zu uns gekommen ist
herzlich willkommen frau klöckner diese
drastischen nur der dramatischen
zustände vor allen dingen in den
unterkünften können wir jetzt mit den
maßnahmen die heute beschlossen haben
davon ausgehen dass die der
vergangenheit angehören sie sollten
schon längst der vergangenheit angehört
haben es gibt
zustände die wir immer wieder sehen
auch in der fleischbranche die weder
unseren sozialstandards nach unserem
verständnis von arbeitsrecht und
arbeitsbedingungen entsprechen und
unternehmen ganz gleich welcher branche
können nicht ihre verantwortung
auslagern am sub sub sub unternehmen und
das haben wir jetzt gerade in der korona
krisen der pandemie zeit erlebt das sehr
auffälliger weise infektionszahlen nach
oben geschossen sind und man wundert
sich na ja wie kann das passieren wenn
viel zu viele menschen in einem haus in
einer wohnung untergebracht sind und ist
zwischen agenturen und händler gibt die
davon
die die da auch beteiligt sind und jeder
seinen teil verdient das geht nicht gut
und deshalb sagen wir ganz klar hier
müssen andere standards wie konnten sie
das überhaupt zu lassen diese zustände
oft oft in den vergangenen jahren ist er
darüber berichtet worden das ist jetzt
ein total neues phänomen jetzt hat die
krone krise noch mal neu ist neuen fokus
darauf geworfen aber wie konnten sie das
überhaupt zu lassen
wir haben sehr klare handelt schon 2000
in der vergangenen legislaturperiode das
war vor meiner zeit als ministerin
wurden arbeitsbedingungen ganz klar
geregelt davor war es so dass die vag
arbeitnehmer die mussten sogar ihre
schutzkleidung oder das handwerkszeug
entweder mieten oder selber bezahlen
das ist gesetzlich abgestellt worden und
es hat sich gezeigt dass trotz
selbstverpflichtungen immer wieder von
einigen die lücken auch ausgenutzt
worden sind das heißt die verantwortung
wurde ausgelagert man hat sich hinter
den subunternehmern auch versteckt und
jetzt kommt einiges zusammen also man
sieht jetzt ein beispiel schauen wir zu
den saison arbeitskräften in der
landwirtschaft da ist die verantwortung
klar da hat der arbeitgeber die
verantwortung für unterkünfte hat die
verantwortung auch für die versorgung
auch für den infektionsschutz und für
die dokumentation und das sehen wir dass
so etwas funktionieren kann
und dort wo jemand sagt das sind nicht
meine arbeitnehmer dann haben wir die
probleme die sie jetzt auch beschrieben
haben also die firma vion westfleisch
turniers und wie sie alle heißen die
dann irgendwo unternehmer beauftragt der
ganz anders heißt und dann rumänen in
unterkünften unterbringt das wird so
nicht mehr geben wenn zukünftig die
großen firmen ihre osteuropäer rumänin
skandalösen zuständen unterbringen dann
sind die ab 20 21 definitiv dafür
verantwortlich richtig wo ein
mitarbeiter her kommt es relativ egal ob
er jetzt aus rumänien kommt aus
osteuropa oder sonstwo her sondern es
muss klare bedingungen menschenwürdige
bedingungen geben und was definitiv ein
ende haben wird wird das auslagern von
verantwortung sein und verträge zu
schließen mit jemand der verträge
geschlossen hat er wiederum mit jemandem
verträge geschlossen hat im übrigen
verdient da jeder mit und derjenige der
am ende ist der verdient am
allerwenigsten kann sich auch nicht
dagegen auflehnen und da sagen wir hier
müssen klarheiten rein dass wir raus
genommen haben zum beispiel heute in dem
kabinettsbeschluss in dieser
beschlussvorlage ist zum beispiel das
regionale fleischerhandwerk da haben wir
ganz andere bedingungen auch und das ist
natürlich selbstverständlich muss das
rechtssicher seien
und ich sage ganz klar es gibt regeln
und die muss man sich halten aber es
gibt auch schlupflöcher und die müssen
geschlossen werden könnte dazu führen
dass die branche nicht ganz so aus der
europäischen zukunft dominiert wird aber
das hat ja auch einen grund viele
deutsche wollen ganz offenbar diesen job
nicht machen das ist ein sehr sehr
harter job dort in den schlachtbetrieben
würde man überhaupt deutsche
arbeitnehmer noch massenhaft dafür
begeistern können in den schlachthöfen
zu arbeiten
das ist ein harter job in der tat und
auch jeder verbraucher sollte sich vor
augen führen wo sein schnitzel oder die
wurst auch herkommt es gibt ja so ein
sondern eine tendenz dass man am
liebsten fleisch essen würde von tieren
die nie geschlachtet worden sind ich
glaube die verantwortung und
wertschätzung gehört auch dazu auch die
achtung vor einem jahr das man auch
fleisch nicht wegwirft das alles sind
sind ist der eine punkt wo wir
verbraucher natürlich auch unsere
verantwortung haben aber der andere
punkt ist ja bei dieser harten arbeit
ist die frage wie attraktiv ist sie in
der bezahlung in den umständen schauen
wir noch mal in die landwirtschaft das
ist auch eine sehr harte arbeit aber da
kommen arbeitskräfte aus osteuropa sie
haben gute bedingungen wir haben vor
allen dingen dort auch nach geschafft
und deshalb ist es für mich kein
argument zu sagen man dürfe jetzt nicht
gesetzliche regelungen oder strenger
regelungen vornehmen bei der
fleischindustrie weil man keine arbeit
findet man findet arbeiter wenn die
bedingungen stimmen ich wollte nochmal
auf meine einstiegsfrage zurück da hatte
ich gefragt gehören diese zustände der
vergangenheit an also das was wir in den
heimen dort gesehen haben 40 leute auf
so viel quadratmeter vielleicht mit
zwölf betten nur oder so untergebracht
das ist vergangenheit in der
vergangenheit angehören sie müssen es
gibt so viele die auch mich jetzt zum
beispiel gestern und die tage
kontaktiert haben wir sprechen von den
schwarzen und den weißen schaffen so
viele so genannte weiße schafe die
ordentliche arbeitsbedingungen bieten
die eben nicht dieses auslagern von
verantwortung praktizieren die uns
gesagt haben ja hier muss nachgebessert
werden und wir wollen auch fairness
haben wenn wir uns ordentlich verhalten
und das ganze geht ja jetzt im parlament
zwischen verlauf beziehungsweise der
arbeitsminister muss ein entsprechendes
gesetz vorlegen das dann auch
rechtssicher ist das ist klar
und insofern meine ich ist das ja eine
ganz große debatte die wir führen über
arbeitsbedingungen über corona
infektionsschutz maßnahmen aber auch
über die frage von tierhaltung von von
fleisch kosten von unserem konsum also
wir sind großer kader sind wir sofort
beim preis weil der heutige beschluss
bedeutet doch eins also wir sind in der
tiefsten rezession in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik wir haben zehn millionen
anträge auf kurzarbeit im moment jetzt
besteht der vatertag bevor am wochenende
werden es 30 grad die grillsaison
beginnt und der beschluss bedeutet doch
fleisch und teurer
der beschluss bedeutet dass die
arbeitsbedingungen besser werden ob
pfleiderer bürger also ich hab noch in
keiner kabinettssitzung beigewohnt die
die preise festsetzt
das hat die folge dass fleisch teurer
nicht unbedingt wenn ganz viele nicht
mehr mitverdienen einem sub sub sub sub
unternehmer
nein wenn er nicht mehr mit verdient
wird also sie dürfen gerne mehr bezahlen
für vielleicht das finde ich auch
richtig und auch gut aber wir sollten
nicht diese schwarz weiß debatte
aufmachen
die schwarz weiß debatte heißt auf der
einen seite das würde ein luxusgut
würden vielleicht das ist es nicht
sondern wichtig wird sein dass fair
bezahlt wird im übrigen dass auch beim
landwirt beim tierhalter genügend
ankommt dass seine familie davon leben
kann und übrigens auch die stand das
umsetzen kann die wir verbraucher uns
wünschen nämlich mehr tierwohl und so
die discounter preise im moment die
super angebote sind die und film ich
finde es unanständig wenn man versucht
mit dumping preisen für fleisch menschen
anzulocken in den supermarkt aber man
hat es ja vom verbraucher wieder das
geld durch mischkalkulation beim
toilettenpapier oder bei ein paar
spritzer und da finde ich die
wertschätzung drückt sich auch in der
wertschöpfung auf und fleisch ist und
auch nahrungsmittel generell dürfen
keine ramschware sein weil dann die
wertschätzung auch singt und man erzählt
sich ja auch seine verbraucher und
nochmal es soll kein luxusgut werden
sind wir weit von entfernt aber wir
geben in deutschland für nahrungsmittel
noch nicht mal 10 unseres
haushaltseinkommens aber handys lassen
wir uns einiges kosten
also das essen ist uns weniger wert
handys sagt die ministerin ganz offenbar
im moment 59 kilo fleisch verzehrt der
durchschnittsdeutsche statistisch pro
jahr 59 kilo erst mal zu viel fleisch
das kann man ja gar nicht so pauschal
sagen es gebe 950 kilo das ja aber das
ist ja auch sehr durchschnitten also
essen sie 59 kilo bin ich gegen
pauschalität deshalb essen wir zu viel
fleisch
die frage ist was ist man wie wie es ist
überhaupt mein main ernährungsverhalten
da spielen ganz viele faktoren eine
rolle
wichtig ist dass man diesen gedanken
sonntagsbratens noch mal anders vor
augen hat also nicht jeden tag in der
woche und dann billiges fleisch sondern
auf qualität achten dann ist auch mehr
tierwohl möglich und es geht um eine
ausgewogene ernährung also obst gemüse
und vieles andere gehört auch zu einer
gesunden ausgewogenen ernährung dazu und
insofern ich habe mal gelesen dass
männer mehr fleisch essen als frauen
liegt wahrscheinlich auch an der
grillsaison ich weiß es nicht aber es
gibt auch veganer vegetarier jeder soll
nach seiner fasson glücklich werden
aber unsere ansprüche müssen mit unserem
eigenen verhalten übereinstimmen müssen
sie wo sie da liegen 59 kilo fleisch im
jahr
das messe das netz ab und ich esse
beileibe nicht jeden tag fleisch oder
wurst dann hätte ich habe versuche
ausgewogen zu ernähren
aber ich kann ihnen das in der kilo zahl
überhaupt nicht sagen ich weiß wir
müssen weg frau klöckner ich will ihn
noch ein gast ganz kurz vorstellen der
wahrscheinlich drüber liegt über den 50
kilo das ist nämlich thomas meurer der
uns zugeschaltet ist aus thüringen der
ist absoluter grillmeister dort hat das
erste deutsche bratwurstmuseum gegründet
herr maurer ich grüße sie zum
mittagszeit was liegt da jetzt bei ihnen
schon auf dem grill um kurz nach 12 uhr
hallo schöne grüße zurück und ja sie
dürfen beim erraten was es gibt heute ja
sagen sie mir es gibt natürlich es gibt
natürlich thüringer bratwurst und
ja aber ich vielleicht kann ich da
gleich einen knüpfen natürlich gibt es
auch nicht bei mir jeden tag bratwurst
zum mittag oder so ich bin auch dafür
dass wir wieder mehr dahin kommen dass
es ein genussmittel wirkt dass es also
wertgeschätzt wird und dass wir
wegkommen von diesem jahr massenkonsum
und von diesen preisverfall bei fleisch
also das deckt sich ganz klar auch mit
unserer intention für die thüringer für
die meisten ist ratlos natürlich eine
wichtige sache das ist eben nicht nur
lebensmittel wirtschaftsgut es ist auch
ein stück thüringer lebensart
herzenssache manche sagen sogar die
thüringer partners ist ein kulturgut und
es ist ja auch so es gibt jede menge
geschichte kultur kunst kitsch und kult
ja um die beliebteste thüringer
spezialität das ist eine tatsache wir
sehen was ihnen das wert ist die
thüringer rostbratwurst natürlich würden
sie für die in zukunft mehr bezahlen
also ich persönlich ja was soll ich
jetzt sagen ich würde sagen ja das sagen
ja die meisten verbraucher auch insofern
ist das in der öffentlichkeit mitunter
sehr unaufrichtig diskussion ich glaube
sie finden nur wenige sie sagen ja ich
bin für katastrophale tier
haltungsbedingungen ich bin dafür dass
die bauern so wenig für ihre rohstoffe
bekommen ich bin dafür dass die umwelt
und menschen die dieses lebensmittel
herstellen unter den arbeitsbedingungen
unter gesundheitsschutz oder umwelt
beeinträchtigungen leiden und schaden
nehmen alle sagen dass sie möchten dass
und alle sagen auch sie würden was mehr
bezahlen aber an der fleischtheke sitz
meistens anders aus und wenn ich mir die
angebots heftchen wieder an gucke jetzt
vor himmelfahrt wo natürlich auch in
thüringen überall der rost brennt dann
ist das eine andere sprache und die
leute gehen an die fleischtheke und
greifen zu diesen angeboten insofern ja
mit den lippenbekenntnissen das ist dann
so eine sache
das ist ja interessant da sie das sagen
herr meurer frau minister in klöckner
selbst der oberste deutsche bratwurst
chef sagt damit ich dann sagt sie uns
doch halt ehrlich dass es durchaus
teurer wird und wir werden am ende doch
auch bereit in der preis sehr drauf
steht vielleicht ein bisschen mehr an
der theke zu bezahlen also das ist ein
ganz entscheidender punkt dass am ende
ja der verbraucher selbst entscheidet
was er kauft aber wir müssen deutlich
machen wenn wir auch mehr tierwohl
wollen das auch mehr beim landwirt
ankommen muss und deshalb sage ich zur
wertschätzung gehört auch wertschöpfung
und will deutlich machen selbst wenn der
preis steigt ist noch nicht
gewährleistet dass die hygiene zustände
in ordnung sind dort wo eben fleisch
verarbeitet werden deshalb glaube ich
müssen wir das ganz ordentlich auch
trennen wenn es um den
endverbraucherpreis geht dann musste er
auch einen wert wiedergeben von einem
produkt und wir müssen schauen ob dieses
geld was er wirtschaft wird auch fair
überall ankommt eben auch beim
tierhalter und dass wir die standards
danke herzlich dass sie zur mittagszeit
bei uns sollen wenn sie das sehen hinten
auf dem grill bekommen sie appetit oder
eher nicht so heute auch doch ja okay
dann ich glaube sie sind sie auch schon
mal begegnet haben wird vielleicht mal
wieder zeit ich danken herzlich für den
wissen